the Kimye and Taylor narrative continues
Sam Smith gets it on the Taylor versus
Kim Feud plus Beyonce's surprise visit
to the sports Person of the Year
ceremony oh guys today really does feel
like hump day
last night was the et holiday party and
the struggle is real now some other
folks who are hurting today Kim
Kardashian and Taylor Swift fans just
when we thought the dust had finally
settled on their infamous feud the shade
came back full swing folks it all
started on Instagram on Monday Kim
posted this throwback photo at her
husband Kanye West's famous exhibit
which featured naked wax figures of
public figures including Taylor now in
case you forgot famous is the song that
first sparked the Kimye Swift feud then
on Tuesday
Taylor posted a photo from her British a
bogus red in the caption I never trust a
narcissist but they love me
it's a lyric from her song I did
something bad and both posts sent fans
into a frenzy with Swifty's flooding
Kim's post with rat emojis savage now
cute fans also posted snake emojis the
same emoji Kim herself used during her
beef with Taylor who then turned around
and used it as a symbol for her
reputation album is keeping up
I'm exhausted over this it also can't
look away and I also can't you sides but
someone who can Sam Smith he's getting
it on the debate and the singer was on
Tuesdays watch what happens live with
Andy Cohen where he was asked about Kim
and Taylor's ongoing feud watch his
response what do you think of the feud
and are you team Taylor or team Kim I
don't really know like Taylor Swift I
don't know her too well I think it's be
made out that we know each other but I
don't know her - I've only met her like
five times very briefly I feel like they
know her her birthday party yeah but I
mean I think a lot of people and yes
I got asked to go and it was great but I
didn't get to chat one-on-one with her
yes I know Kim more than I know Taylor
Oh is Taylor Swift Sam Smith's next
goodbye guys which side are you on
comment with a snake or rat emoji right
now I want to see I want to know but you
know who has no beef with anybody
Beyonce
Queen be surprised the crowd at Sports
Illustrated's sports Person of the Year
awards to present Colin Kaepernick with
the Muhammad Ali Legacy Award Tuesday
night she paid tribute to the former NFL
star and share her appreciation for the
outspoken public protest he started when
he took a knee during the national
anthem protesting police brutality and
racial inequality
ladies and gentlemen I'm so proud and
humbled to present the Muhammad Ali
legacy award to Colin Kaepernick I
accept this award knowing that the
legacy of Muhammad Ali is that of a
champion of the people and one who was
affectionately known as the people's
champ I accept this award not for myself
but on behalf of the people because if
it were not for my love for the people I
would not have protested you can catch
Beyonce's tribute and call its entire
speech this Friday at 8 p.m. Eastern on
the NBC Sports Network
now speaking of be the man behind
Beyonce's iconic single ladies dance and
the any Rd and Rihanna lemon video joke
well night was recently named one of
Forbes 30 under 30 to make sense because
as I found out Jack well is cooking up
something special with Yonsei for her
headlining set at Coachella
let's look take it back though to the
very beginning one of your first gigs
was choreographing a little music video
by the name of single ladies
[Music]
I mean come on that I don't think there
is a more iconic dance or choreography
than like Michael Jackson Thriller how
does it feel to know that you're a part
of such like a pop culture phenomenon oh
my god you know single ladies is still a
moment that I have yet to put into words
you know the impact that that piece have
had on culture and you know music and
jazz what I've done for Beyonce email
right you know it's just mind-blowing
you know and just the impact that it has
on people and how they have how they
still kind of turn up to it and still do
the routines and ya know it's something
that's gonna hopefully last forever I'm
still doing it I'm still do it it's like
thank you I mean I watched it I watched
a lot of time so you've worked with
Beyonce on the Super Bowl performances
yes formation of course we know next
you're her next high profile gig will be
Coachella yes be ready for a good time
yeah I have a good old time we're
getting ready for Coachella and you know
that's gonna change the game and super
excited what's one word you can tease to
describe her Coachella performance one
word amazing beyond iconic life like oh
thank you all right we'll just have to
wait until next April when B brings the
fire to Coachella and we'll be there
with bells whistles and a leotard okay
are you guys be sure to hit subscribe
and if you like this video then you
should have put a ring on it